foreign
Marvel Studios black panther wakanda
forever is roaring onto the big screen
and I am sitting down with the cast and
director Ryan coogler to talk all about
it so let's get to it for our cast where
do we find your characters at the
beginning of the film we find shuri in
her lab
going through some tough emotions and we
are about to explore the ways in which
she has to unpack those difficult
emotions you find my character doing her
job but it's in a new time there's a
loss of a dear dear leader and a dear
brother to her so she's really come to a
place where she's not experiencing the
world the same but she's seeking to take
care of others she has grown a lot since
the last time we saw her been through a
lot her priorities have shifted and
sharpened we find raimonda on the throne
as Queen leader of the wakanda nation we
find no more kicking kicking some asses
protecting his people now speaking of
wakanda I know I would want to visit who
wouldn't want to visit but if you could
go what would you want to see first I
would want to go to RiverTown first
that's where Nakia is from and when you
see the renderings of this place man
it's so beautiful I would want to go to
the throne room first and then I
wouldn't mind taking a side trip to
jubari land I personally would want to
see the throne room respectfully of
course no loud talking now there are so
many great characters being introduced
and fan favorites returning in this
movie what two characters from the film
would you want to see team up I would
love to see
General Ocoee
anatuma work side to side like who would
be dumb enough to mess with a koye and
atuma at the same time I would want to
see Baku and nomura she's small and he's
large and they're both skilled one on
the water and one on land so many good
scenes between characters from my
perspective I enjoy directing you know
and show you scenes with more are really
cool they're really strong they kind of
speak the same acting language it was
great to watch them to watch them work
together and to watch like the chemistry
like the electricity between them well
there are so many incredible parts of
this film but what are you all most
excited for fans to see everything
there's so much action uh we got
underwater action in the air action and
the languages you know we got French we
got Spanish we got Mayan and the action
did I say action you can discover
these two worlds we are going in a
little bit deeper in wakanda and we have
this new world chalokan I'm most excited
for fans to see the the characters that
they've come to love and admire and I'm
also excited for them to see new faces
pop up I hope that the audience feels
the love that we have for our friend and
why we love them and I think if we
succeed in terms of that then the themes
of the film are true the fact that
somebody can be gone in the physical
sense they're not truly gone
well you heard it here first you are not
going to want to miss this everyone go
get your tickets to Marvel Studios black
panther wakanda forever coming
exclusively to theaters November 11th
foreign